we now continue the study of the sum of
a random number of independent random
variables we already figured out what is
the expected value of this sum and we
found a fairly simple answer when it
comes to the variance however it's
pretty hard to guess what the answer
will be and it turns out that the answer
is not as simple so this is what we will
try to calculate now the way to proceed
will be to use the law of total variance
which effectively breaks down the
problem by conditioning on the value of
the random variable capital n so let us
start we have already figured out that
if I tell you the value of capital n
then the expected value of the random
variable Y is just this number capital n
the number of stores you are visiting
times how much you are spending in each
one of the stores using this information
we can now calculate this term the
variance of the conditional expectation
what is it
it's the variance of capital n times the
expected value of X now the expected
value of x is a constant and when we
multiply a random variable with a
constant what that does to the variance
is it multiplies the variance with the
square of that constant and this gives
us this term in the law of total
variance
let us now work towards the second term
if I tell you the number of stores then
the random variable Y is just a sum of a
given number of random variables and as
we discussed before the conditioning
that we have here may be eliminated
because these random variables are now
independent of this random variable
capital n their distribution does not
change based on this information and so
we obtain the unconditional
variants now the unconditional variance
of a sum of n random variables is just n
times the variance of each one of them
which we denote with this notation now
let us take this equality which is an
equality between numbers and it's true
for any particular choice of little end
and turn it into an equality between
random variables this is the random
variable that takes this specific value
when capital n is equal to little n so
this is a random variable that takes
this specific value when capital n is
equal to little n but this is also the
same as this random variable n times the
variance of X because this random
variable takes this particular numerical
value when capital n is equal to little
n now that we have an expression for the
conditional variance as a random
variable we can take the next step and
calculate the expected value of the
conditional variance the expected value
of the conditional variance is simply
the expected value of this expression
that we calculated up here and now the
variance of X is a constant and can be
pulled outside the expectation which
leaves us with this expression here now
that we have calculated both terms that
go into the law of total variance we can
add these two terms we have one
contribution from here this is this term
and another contribution from here which
is this term what this expression tells
us is that the variance of the total
amount that you spend which is a certain
measure of the amount of randomness in
how much you're spending overall this
amount of randomness is due to two
causes one cause is the randomness that
there is in how much money you spend in
any given store and that's captured by
the very
of X it's the variance of the
distribution of the amount of money that
you spend in a typical store but there
is another source of randomness and that
source of randomness comes from the fact
that the number of stores itself is
random and this gives us this
contribution to the variance of Y by
taking into account these two sources of
randomness we can figure out the overall
variance of the random variable Y as you
can see this is a formula that would be
hard to get by just reasoning
intuitively and so it's a demonstration
of the power of the law of the total
variance